[Musique]
faire de la science de manière ouverte
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus efficace et
c'est comme ça que devrait être la
science de base c'est comme ça qu'elle
était à la base en ce moment il ya un
mouvement que depuis quelques années
pour le libre accès on y va
inexorablement la question c'est comment
on y va je vais commencer par vous
parler de commun alors c'est quoi un
commun à ces trois choses
c'est une ressource qui peut être
matériel ou immatériel
si un mode d'accès à la ressource et les
règles de son partage et enfin c'est la
gouvernance de cette ressource
le but de la gouvernance d'une ressource
c'est d'un commun c'est d'essayer de
conserver le commun de le rendre pérenne
et de garder son existence d'accord
alors c'est un peu abstrait donc je vous
planter tout de suite un exemple le
verger d'un village d'accord donc là la
ressource et des pommes ok le mode
d'accès on va cueillir les pommes dans
l'arbre chacun peut aller se servir les
règles ça va être quoi on a droit de
prendre que deux tonnes par personne et
par semaine
et quand on y va il faut qu'on arrose et
qu'on enlève les mauvaises herbes ont
participé un petit peu on reste une demi
heure ça nous fait une balade et voilà
et la gouvernance elle peut être assurée
par une association le conseil municipal
pour que ya pas de triche
ça c'est un copain matériel donc c'est à
dire que je prends une pomme dans
l'arbre elle n'y est plus maintenant je
vous parlais dans notre comme un
matériel que vous connaissez déjà tous
et toutes
c'est wikipédia donc là la ressource
elle est immatériel c'est du savoir
encyclopédique le mode d'accès c'est par
internet
on y accède par copie dire que quand je
vais chercher une page sur wikipédia je
la récupère mais il est toujours sur
wikipédia pour que quelqu'un d'autre
puisse la prendre et les règles alors il
ya une règle très formel c'est la
licence creative commons qui a utilisé
par wikipedia c'est à dire que vous
pouvez récupérer le contenu sur
wikipédia ou comment faire ce que vous
voulez le réutiliser le remix et le
traduire à conditions que vous citiez le
fait que ça vient de wikipédia moment où
vous le redistribuer et la gouvernance
de wikipédia est un peu complexe
il ya d'abord la fondation wikimedia qui
essaye d'assurer donc vous avez tous
déjà vu les campagnes de dons par
exemple les ressources en termes de
serveurs de bande passante sur le réseau
etc
ensuite chaque encyclopédie donc elles
sont par lang se gère de manière
autonome au niveau 2
ses représentants les administrateurs
des modérateurs donc elles vont
collectivement définir des rôles comment
les gens sont élus et combien de temps
il reste en poste
et quelles sont leurs pouvoirs etc et
ensuite il ya une gouvernance encore
plus décentralisée par exemple contre le
vandalisme et ça c'est c'est chacun de
nous quand on va sur la sur une page
wikipédia on peut corriger des petites
erreurs
et puis chaque article à une page de
discussion qui permet de discuter de est
ce que cette page a le mérite vraiment
d'être sur wikipédia quel contenu elle
doit avoir et c'est donc la gouvernance
est assuré comme ça il ya un truc qui
s'appelle la tragédie des communs un
tricheur dans ce système là il est
toujours gagnant donc si je reprends
l'exemple du verger dit quelqu'un
l'hiver pendant qu'il ya pas de pomme
vient a besoin de se chauffer et coupe
du bois le commun il meurt c'est pour ça
que la gouvernance est particulièrement
importante pour imaginer d'autres
situations par exemple quelqu'un qui
prend toutes les pommes pour faire de la
compote et la vendent donc il ya plein
de plein de situations envisagées mais
c'est facile très facile de s'imaginer
comment on peut faire mourir un comme un
matériel mais pour un commun immatériel
ça peut paraître moins évident et
pourtant c'est possible
donc je vais vous présenter un univers
alternatif où c'est un autre wikipédia
vous avez changé de logo génie un euro
vous allez voir pourquoi donc ces ya un
prince et un autre univers où ben on
peut tous et toutes rédiger des articles
c'est comme sur le wikipedia actuelle
mais on a un espèce de devoir en tant
que citoyen de corriger les articles
quand on voit des erreurs pas toujours
mais on aime ça fait partie de notre
rôle on est censé au moins de temps en
temps participer à ça quand on veut
accéder à un article on doit le payer 30
euros on peut se dire c'est pas trop
cher et des articles de super bonne
qualité ça vaut le coup rien n'est aussi
où on aurait bien aimé voir ce que
c'était avant de payer 30 euros 1 puis
le problème qu'on a surtout c'est que
quand on accède à un article pour le
comprendre il faut comprendre aussi les
articles des concepts qu'il utilise lui
même donc on va devoir payer plein
d'articles vous inquiétez pas c'est pas
des escrocs non plus il ya des
abonnements pourquoi ça c'est possible
ça pourrait ça pourrait vraiment se
passer comme ça pourquoi c'est possible
parce qu'un truc qui existe il s'appelle
la propriété intellectuelle et nos
terreurs prix d'intellectuels lucrative
et donc ça ça permet d'avoir une
appropriation privée d'un travail
collectif et au passage de créer
artificiellement de la rareté et donc de
retomber sur une économie comme sur
quelque chose de matériel ou quand je le
vois quelqu'un moi je les plus et ben
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne dans la
recherche dans notre vraiment pas dans
le padd en ligne
alternatif et ça c'est un vrai problème
donc comme pas tout le monde ici a
priori ne connaît le fonctionnement de
la recherche s'est très rapidement de
vous expliquer comment ça marche alors
c'est fonctionnement très globale etc
d'accord c'est dans chaque domaine
particuliers et des petites différences
évidemment mais en gros on commence par
rechercher une question première étape
ça suppose qu'on a un accès à des tas de
l'art et l'idée c'est de se dire qu'est
ce que ça va être la bonne prochaine
petite étape pour faire avancer notre
domaine
ça suppose qu'on connaisse notre état de
l'art et l'état des domaines voisins
donc qu'on ait accès aux articles
notamment
ensuite on fait de la recherche à
recherchent une réponse ça peut être
collecté des données les analyses et
créer du logiciel ça peut être plein de
choses selon les domaines
et puis à un moment donné on a des
résultats que ce soit ce qu'on attendait
ou non on en a et quand on veut
communiquer ses résultats parce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on rédige un article donc
un article de recherche et ensuite cet
article on le soumet à une revue une
conférence un journal je veux juste dire
vu pour la suite c'est plus simple une
fois qu on le soumet cette revue donc
une revue c'est quoi c'est quelque chose
d'assez contraire c'est un ensemble
d'autres chercheurs de notre domaine qui
vont récupérer l'article soit le
l'évaluer eux mêmes soit l'envoyer à
évaluer à des gens qui sont plus experts
que eux du domaine et si cet article il
est jugé comme étant assez novateur
rigoureux pertinent par rapport à la
thématique de la revue bas il va être
publié ok sinon il est rejeté où il ya
des allers-retours pour l'améliorer je
sais ce qu'ils soient publiés alors j'ai
mis des guillemets en retour de
publication c'est pas pour rien puisque
publication normand ça veut dire rendu
public et on va voir que c'est un peu
plus compliqué parce que c'est à cette
étape là qu'interviennent les maisons
d'édition et à ce moment-là ce qu'elles
demandent en fait c'est qu'on leur
transfert les droits d'auteur ou le
copyright selon les législations de
l'article pour qu'elle puisse
l'exploiter commercialement en échange
de quoi elle vend le distribuer et donc
du coup on se retrouve avec de l'argent
public qui finance la recherche une
privatisation des résultats de la
recherche en échange de rien et de
l'argent public qui rachète cette
recherche là c'est aussi de l'argent
public qui l'a évalué et c'est alors je
parle beaucoup de recherche publique
il ya aussi de la recherche privée mais
lors d'une part dans le privé la plupart
du temps on publie - et ensuite il faut
savoir que par exemple en france via des
mécanismes de crédit d'impôt etc
la recherche industrielle et
très largement subventionnée par de
l'argent public aussi juste quelques
chiffres très rapidement le nsc en
institution qui est assez petit en
taille
c'est un million d'euros par an de
dépenses documentaire sachant qu'ils
profitent très largement notamment des
accès du cnrs qui dépensent annuellement
un peu plus de 30 millions dont
quasiment 40 millions cette année là et
profite des accès des universités autour
il ya des unités mixtes de recherche
donc par exemple jussieu juste pour elle
c'est dire donc je la fais une fête qui
est juste à côté de nsc un million
d'euros par an aussi juste pour un
éditeur donc un gros abonnement on peut
s'intéresser aussi à l'évolution de ces
prix là donc par exemple à télécom
paristech où j'ai fait ma thèse c'est ça
devenait trop cher donc on a réduit le
nombre d'abonnements de revue au format
papier
de plus de la moitié en échange de quoi
pour que les chercheurs puissent
continuer à travailler on a quand même
pris un tiers d'abonnement web
en plus on a réduit non seulement le
nombre d'abonnements et puis en plus on
prend du web ça veut dire que l'on
télécharge juste les pdf qu'on en a
besoin on reçoit pas le papier par la
poste sous vêtements chair que dalle ça
coûte plus cher et puis pas un petit peu
plus cher et du coup en écho à cette
ruine des bibliothèques universitaires
vous avez les profite donc du chef de
file reed elsevier donc les chiffres là
c'est en milliards de dollars américains
vous voyez le taux bénéfices sur chiffre
d'affaires il est monstrueux alors
comment on en est arrivé là
pourquoi il ya cette situation c'est que
les maisons d'édition elles ont un rôle
alors historiquement ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'elle était en charge de la mise
en page des articles de les distribuer
le plus largement possible
évidemment c'est des trucs privé faut
donner de l'argent et puis faire
connaître les chercheurs elles ont
mérité un petit peu aussi ce qui s'est
passé en fait c'est que au moment où la
diffusion de la science est structurée
autour de journaux bas au début ces
journaux il était détenu par les
académies et des associations savantes
et puis il ya eu un besoin
d'industrialiser la diffusion des
journaux et c'est là que les maisons
d'édition sont entrés en jeu se sont
concentrés et ont privatisé la recherche
en disant on prend le contrôle des
journaux on demande des droits
d'exploitation pour les distribuer dans
le monde et c'était un service dont on
avait besoin avait pas internet à
l'époque
et puis je faisais au passage la mise en
page des articles etc
bon alors il se trouve que de plus en
plus
la mise en page des articles elle est
faite par les chercheurs eux mêmes elle
est chercheuse elle même d'un des outils
comme la tech etc des template pour les
deux les traitements de texte donc ça
s'est fait par nous d'y trouver le plus
largement des les articles sabah
internet le fait très bien
on n'a plus besoin des maisons d'édition
qui amène physiquement dans les pays du
monde entier
les papiers gagner de l'argent comme ça
on a vu que ça se passait plutôt bien la
question c'est est-ce que c'est légitime
de se faire de l'argent sur la
connaissance et puis faire connaître les
chercheurs ça c'est un rôle dont elles
ont hérité et dont elles se sont dotées
elles mêmes aussi via la bibliométrie
très rapidement la bibliométrie c'est
l'idée qu'on va évaluer les chercheurs
de manière quantitative sur leur nombre
de publications donc évidemment une
incitation à la publication ce qui fait
que quand les maisons d'édition se sont
approprié les journaux les chercheurs
ont perdu leurs moyens de production
ils en sont plus maîtres et la biométrie
c'est un peu les méthodes de management
ou en leur fils on leur fixe des
objectifs qui vide le sens de ce qu'ils
font dire que maintenant l'objectif
quand on veut une carrière universitaire
ça va être de faire une publication en
plus c'est pas une découverte en plus
évidemment les outils de bibliométrie
sont vendus par les maisons d'édition et
c'est elles qui font les sa rivale
scopus et c'est qu'elles vendent aussi
très cher aux agences de moyens je vous
parle dessous depuis tout à l'heure on
est dans un pays riche
donc on pourrait se dire bon ben on paye
et puis ça va quoi c'est pas vraiment le
problème principal
le problème c'est l'accès citoyens
l'égalité entre les étudiants les
chercheurs et les universités dans le
monde entier
ça évidemment vous imaginez bien que en
france on peut se le payer mais il ya
des tas de pays où c'est pas le cas
d'accord et où donc on a des
opportunités manquées qui peuvent être
colossal de chercheurs qui pourraient
avoir des idées géniales mais n'ont pas
accès à l'état de l'art et du coup ne
peuvent pas et puis on peut penser aussi
simplement à toutes les start up qui
pourrait profiter des résultats des
derniers résultats de la recherche
fondamentale et qui n'ayant pas accès du
coup andré en réponse à ça le libre
accès se pose comme une espèce de
solutions on va mettre les résultats de
la recherche en ligne accessible
gratuitement
c'est une définition qui est très large
voire beaucoup trop large
bienvenue à beaucoup de mises en oeuvre
possible donc je vais leur a présenté
très rapidement 3 alors versé la voie
verte l'auto archivage ou l'idée c'est
que c'est les chercheurs eux mêmes qui
vont mettre une copie de leurs articles
en ligne sur des dépôts pérenne
j'insiste sur les dépôts pérenne tous
les académies à points est dur et serge
gates et tout ça qui font qu'ils
essayent de faire du bien
ça marche pas donc l' avantage c'est que
ces parallèles aux circuits
traditionnels de publication on peut
aussi mettre des anciens articles en
ligne et puis ça fait prendre conscience
aux chercheurs de l'importance de tout
ça aussi au passage ensuite on a ce
qu'on a appelé la voix doré ont cédé 107
redorer ses 107 bien parce qu'on se
disait gérant va faire de la publication
directement en libre accès le rêve c'est
que les maisons d'édition très
rapidement se sont emparés de ça et on
n'y voit pas de problème mais du coup on
paye pour publier alors ça coûterait
beaucoup trop cher à des institutions
comme le cnrs qui produisent énormément
d'articles ça ne pourrait pas survivre
plus d'un an à sion à ce modèle là
sachant que publier ça coûte très cher
dans ce modèle là plusieurs milliers de
dollars en général et en plus on peut se
poser très légitimement la question de
est ce que c'est normal que l'argent
rentre en compte dans le mode
scientifique de qu'est-ce qu'on publie
ou pas et donc il ya une troisième voie
que celle que je viens de défendre
aujourd'hui qu'on appelle voix diamant
qui s'appelle aussi platinum ou faire
open access ou la lidc beaucoup plus
précis et je reviens sur ce dont je vous
parlais au début c'est de faire de la
recherche
un commun donc l'idée c'est d'aller vers
une abolition de la propriété lucrative
de la connaissance
d'accord il ya aucune raison que la
connaissance soit une propriété privée
avec lequel on fasse de l'argent et que
les chercheurs se réapproprient leurs
moyens de production principal qui est
le moyen de diffusion de leur savoir et
avec lequel ils peuvent construire par
dessus donc on va faire l'exercice c'est
quoi la ressource bon bah on l'a compris
c'est les résultats de la recherche les
articles et données le logiciel etc
le mode d'accès les règles de partage
via internet
c'est universel le plus qu'on puisse le
faire d'accord toujours des barrières de
la langue de l'accès était fermé pour
l'instant n'a pas mieux
utilisation de logiciels et licences
libres évidemment puisque ça sert à rien
de sortir d'une cage pour entrer dans
une autre et la gouvernance l'idée ça
serait que les auteurs conservent leurs
droits d'auteur et leur copyright et les
comités du torrio ce conte se dote d'une
existence légale c'est pas le cas
actuellement et détiennent les revues
alors pourquoi les auteurs conservent
leur copyright simplement parce que
l'intérêt d'un auteur d'un article
scientifique c'est d'être lu et donc
sans intérêt y sont alignés avec ceux du
reste de la population
c'est à dire que ce en afrique soit le
plus accessible possible c'est une idée
réaliste et qui a un coût quasi nul
pourquoi parce que les infrastructures
sont déjà là on a déjà des dépôts
institutionnels et disciplinaires qui
marche dans lequel on peut mettre les
articles et les données et les logiciels
on a déjà des plateformes libres des
logiciels libres
vu par les pairs et d'organisation de
journaux donc là je le cite observée
pour les conférences et open journal
système pour les journaux le cadre légal
il existe la licence creative commons
quand même telles qu'elles sont
utilisées par wikipedia notamment et
licences creative commons attribution
qui correspond exactement à ce qu'on
fait en recherche c'est-à-dire sites et
les blogs sur lesquels on se base pour
faire votre cherche à nous avant les
associations à but non lucratif pour les
comités ditoriaux ça existe déjà s'est
reconnue internationalement et c'est des
choses qui sont déjà dans les pratiques
très rapidement une des pires vue c'est
exactement comme une un journal
classique sauf que plutôt que de publier
un volume à la fin en papier ou en pdf
sur internet en publie une page web avec
une liste de liens vers les versions
accepter des articles et sinon tout se
passe exactement comme avant il ya juste
on n'a plus la variable maison d'édition
qui rentre en compte tout le reste passe
exactement comme avant et après on peut
même imaginer de dépasser des modèles
actuels avec l'évaluation ouvert sous
l'unité de publications deviendrait
l'article et il serait accompagné de ses
revues qui serait signé en ça ça demande
un peu de changement de mentalité de
moeurs et tout ça mais ça pour peut
imaginer aller plus loin comme ça
[Applaudissements]